welcome to downtown las vegas casual
john with you here on fremont east we're
here because of the mint 400 which is
this weekend it is back the legendary
desert race here in southern nevada it's
back and thank god thank goodness it's
back it's such an amazing event matt
martelly's here for the mid 400. matt's
good to see you again this year likewise
i'm glad to be back yeah so for those
who aren't aware of the mint 400 what is
it and and how important is it to
off-road racing in nevada well it's the
biggest baddest off-road race on the
planet right and it started here in 1968
in las vegas on fremont street at the
old mint 400 hotel so it's part of the
legacy of las vegas it went away for a
few years came back obviously it's been
going strong what can folks expect this
year we have over 400 racers racing with
us
two days of racing out at state line at
prim so it's going to be an amazing
event we've got a full day of off road
festival here on thursday on fremont
street so it's going to be packed and
there's the parade of course up las
vegas boulevard on thursday as well
which is always a cool event and maybe
folks need to understand that it's not
it's there's this here in downtown but
the the fun is going to try and see them
in the desert if folks want to go see
some some really proper desert racing
how can they take part and see it it's
super easy i mean this is a spectator
friendly event we have four remote
spectating areas we still have some
tickets available for those as well as
the start finish and prim and there's
lots of vendors and food and activities
going on out there
both on friday and saturday we talked
about how the pandemic has affected so
many things obviously events like this
would be affected as well normally the
mint 400 isn't in december normally
you're in march
how have you had to recalibrate
everything to make it happen this year
well just like america is tough off-road
racing is tough and so we can roll with
the punches so yeah we were supposed to
have to have the event march but kovit
changed the plans and we're here in
december doing a full event next year
we'll be back in march on the regular
dates second weekend in march but you
know you can't stop off-road racing
we're going to race pandemic no pandemic
and come out and enjoy the vitamin d and
make yourself healthy matt martelly from
the mid-400 what else should people know
if they want to head out and check out
just a really cool event thursday
downtown on fremont street is our our
off-road festival that's free and open
to the public you can buy tickets online
for the race for friday and saturday
we have over 400 racers racing with us
as well as a lot of celebrities
one of the big ones jesse james is
coming this year and racing with us in
his unlimited truck a lot of local
racers of course from southern nevada
got lots of dirt racers in the valley as
well that'll be taking part in the
mid-400 matt it's good to see you again
glad the mint is back this year looking
forward to seeing some racing down the
desert this year appreciate it glad
you're here as well